All right.
Good morning. Welcome to this gathering of Henderson Hills.
It's not New Year yet,
but we can kind of say Happy New Year, I guess, right?
Uh, if you are new to our church,
we're thankful you would choose to be with us today.
Uh, we know it's, it's a big step
to venture into a new place maybe for the first time,
or you've been here a couple times,
but we're grateful you're here.
Please introduce yourself to us.
Come let us know that you're here, uh,
either up here at the front after the service
or at the new here area out there.
We'd love to meet you. There's a QR code in the seat back if
you want to do that as well.
Now, today we'll be a,
a little bit different than a normal worship gathering
because we are kicking off a week of prayer today.
And so this whole week ahead of us will be, uh,
various gatherings throughout the week.
You can see that on your little, uh, announcement sheet
that you got coming in to see it on the
website, either, either way.
But what we're gonna do today is, is kick that off in a way
with, uh, a, a, a gathering of prayer that will be led
with songs of praise, times of prayer,
where you'll be involved, you'll be receiving,
you'll be giving in some ways as well.
We won't ask you to pray out loud if you're not
comfortable with that yet.
But we do want you to know that this is participation,
involvement is what we're asking today,
because the more you get into it,
the more you will get out of it as well.
Now, we often talk about revival.
Uh, the church in America needs to be revived,
needs revival, or, uh, an awakening, those kind of things,
seeing people turn back to God.
That's good of course, to desire that.
But I know that I often am tempted to merely want that
without anything involved.
Like just God do something. We want revival.
Well, here's what someone said about that.
To desire revival.
And at the same time, neglect prayer
and devotion is to wish one way and walk another.
And so when we look at what God says about his at the time,
the, the temple, Jesus said, this is a house
of prayer for all nations.
Now we know that that's not a building anymore
because we as the people of God are the temple.
So we are still to be a house of prayer.
And so prayer's a significant part
of the relationship we have with God as the all nations.
Now that we are, it's worship.
And so we're going to participate in that as the house
of prayer because we can approach the throne of God,
the Lord's presence through Christ.
Hebrews force has led us approach God's throne of grace
with confidence so that we may receive mercy
and find grace to help us in our time of need.
So that's gonna be the theme of today,
to approach the throne of God with confidence
because we are needy people.
Let that be the theme of our day today as we walk
through this journey together.
Uh, let's participate with that being our filter today
and all week.
So we continue our time of prayer.
We want to next practice meditating and awaiting.
And what does that mean exactly?
The world has lots of suggestions for how
to meditate these days,
but biblical meditation is simply taking time
to think deeply about God's word.
It's not the process of clearing your mind,
as the gurus might say,
but of filling your mind with scripture or with truth.
Uh, the word meditation simply means to chew on
or to absorb.
If you think about how you chew food versus
how you chew gum, we chew food for just a few seconds
and we swallow it, but then we might chew gum for hours
absorbing all of its flavor.
And that's biblical meditation,
and that's what we want to do this morning.
So listen to a few of these verses.
Joshua one, eight, this book of the law, God's word
shall not depart from your mouth,
but you shall meditate on it.
Chew on it, day and night.
Psalm one, verse three.
Blessed is the man who delights in the law.
The Lord God's word on his law.
He meditates or choose day and night.
Psalm one 19, how I love your law God's word.
It's my meditation all day long.
We wanna take a minute to meditate
on a particular passage outta Psalm 62.
So let me read this slowly, carefully.
I'll make a few comments and then we'll pray together.
Psalm 62, verse five, for God alone, oh my soul,
wait in silence.
For my hope is from him.
He only is my rock in my salvation, my fortress,
I shall not be shaken
on my God, rest my salvation
and my glory, my mighty rock.
My refuge is God.
Trust in Him at all times
and pour out your heart before him.
God is a refuge for us.
So what's being said in Psalm 62 verses five through eight?
Our hope is in God alone.
Why notice the names that the psalmist uses for God.
He's our rock, our fortress, our refuge,
our salvation, and our glory.
And why does any of that matter?
Because we can trust in Him at all times.
Whatever we're facing, we will not be shaken.
'cause we can trust in Him. How do we do that?
Psalm says, pour out your heart to the Lord
and wait in silence for him to respond.
You know, waiting might be the hardest part of prayer.
We know to pray, we know the things to say in a prayer,
but waiting, waiting is difficult.
Waiting might be the hardest part of prayer.
Sometimes God responds immediately.
Sometimes he takes days, weeks,
even longer than that.
So what do we do while we are waiting for God to respond,
we pray, pray some more.
We listen in silence.
We meditate, chew on God's word on truth.
We wait in expectation for him to answer us.
We rest.
The Bible says in Him, we, we we're not anxious.
We have peace. We won't be shaken.
We, we, we run to him as our refuge.
So let's do that right now.
Wherever you're at right now in your life, in your,
in this time of the year,
whatever's happening circumstance wise, let's take a minute
to pray and wait for God to answer.
So right there where you're at in your seat, take a moment
to pour out your heart
to the Lord he loves you, he caress for you.
He wants to hear from you. Speak to him right now.
What are those things that concern you right now?
What are those things that are weighing you down?
Give them to the Lord.
Lay them at his feet and ask for his help.
One of the things that happens
as you wait on the Lord in prayer is he'll convict you of
where you've fallen short of the glory of God sin.
And so we move now into a time of confession.
Now, to confess your sins to God is not to tell him anything
that he doesn't already know.
But what it is is restoring the relationship
as you clear out the clouds that have
have hidden that relationship.
It doesn't mean he went anywhere. He didn't go anywhere.
You did. And so the idea is to clear that out
and confess and experience his cleansing forgiveness
as one John one, nine says, when we confess our sins,
he's faithful and just to forgive us of our sins
and to cleanse us from all our unrighteousness.
And that's drawing back into that relationship
that we already had as a believer with him.
We're not getting re-saved,
we're just restoring a relationship.
But to, to confess and,
and to ask for forgiveness demands something,
it demands that we first admit that we need it.
That we need forgiveness for something
that we first confess humbly.
Because instinctively we, we wiggle,
we point the finger like Adam
and Eve did in the garden at someone else.
Instead, we need to humbly recognize each of us as a sinner,
recognize where we've fallen short, confess that
to the Lord, agree with him in that,
that we've sinned against him.
And so we're gonna leave some space here. Quiet.
Uh, we don't often get quiet in our lives.
So this space is a time for you, just by yourself, quietly
confessing to the Lord where you know
and he agree with him, you've fallen shore.
So take some time as he prompts you.
Um, he will, he will answer that prayer.
Psalm 1 39, search my heart and know me right now.
Do that quietly by yourself.
Then I'll lead us through some times
together throughout history.
There's also been times of corporate gathered confession
where someone confesses sin on behalf of the whole.
So I wanna do that now with some scripture
and some prayers in a pastoral way to care
for our own hearts, to recognize where we need to as a body
or as individuals confess to the Lord.
We've already sang it today,
but Psalm 1 35, 15 through 18 says, the idols
of the nations are silver and gold.
The work of human hands, they have mouths but don't speak.
They have eyes but don't see they have ears, but don't hear,
nor is there breath in their mouths.
Those who make the idols become like them.
So do all who trust in them. Confession can be a hard thing.
'cause again, it's humbling
to admit your failure, admit your weakness.
But remember this, as you confess,
there is more grace in God than sin in you.
Pray is God. And so not only do we have a time
of confession, we have a time of assurance
because the reality is we come broken.
And the assurance we have when we come broken
to the Lord is the cross of Christ
who showed his love for us by pouring out his blood
to atone for our sin.
All that you've just confessed, all you didn't even want
to confess, yet all you will confess later
that's covered under the blood of Christ.
That is the assurance we have.
And so walk into that as you have
received this conviction of sin
and confessed it, received the forgiveness,
walk in the beauty walk like the son did in the parable
of the prodigal son, walk home like he did.
You might think, I don't have the words.
I don't know how to say it right, so that God will forgive
so that I can come home.
Listen, it was never the son's speech
that brought him home, right?
It was merely the fact that he came
Home. Yes,
Yes. And his father
was looking for
Him.
So come home.
If you're looking for words though, maybe you're like, okay,
I don't know what to even say.
Well, okay, here's an illustration from God's word,
king David sin in probably the deepest way you can ever
imagine sinning
and hiding it, lying about it,
when that sin was exposed, gave one
of the greatest prayers of repentance. You'll ever
See Psalm 51, have mercy on me.
Oh God, according to your unfailing love,
according to your great compassion,
blot out my transgressions.
Wash away all my iniquity. Cleanse me from my sin.
For I know my transgressions, my sin is always before me.
So create in me a pure heart, oh God,
renew a steadfast spirit within me.
God, I've come home,
Do a work in me All
because we have an advocate.
We have a substitute. His name is Jesus Christ.
And so before the throne of God,
we have someone standing there who counts for us.
So we're gonna sing that in assurance
that we have a savior.
As we enter into a time of intercessory prayer,
I think it's important that we understand
what intercessory prayer is
and what our example from scripture really is.
And so as I thought about this, um,
what better example do we have than Christ himself?
If we look at the pages of John, uh, chapter 17,
we see Christ having a conversation with God the Father.
And he's talking to him about how he has fulfilled
what needed to be done here on earth, knowing full well
that he's about to be betrayed and crucified.
And in the midst of that, in verse eight, it says,
for I have given them the words that you gave me.
And they have received them
and have come to know in the truth that I came from you
and they have believed that you sent me.
I am praying for them.
I'm not praying for the world,
but for those whom you have given me for, they are yours.
So in the midst of Jesus knowing what is coming,
he stops and he's praying for the disciples.
He's interceding for them. He's petitioning the Lord.
And even he goes on in verse 20, he talks about others
that have believed and how he prays for them as well.
And if we jump over to, uh, Romans chapter eight,
verse 34, it talks about how Christ
is seated at the right hand of the Father interceding
on our behalf, knowing what we need,
praying for forgiveness of sin, saying to God the Father
that I've covered that saying that
he will sustain us, saying that he will provide for us,
that he'll give us comfort, he'll give us peace.
So we have that person in Jesus
who is interceding on our behalf.
And John 1334
and 35 says that the way that the world will know
that we are his is by how we love each other.
And what better way to express our love
for one another than to pray for each other.
And so I want to invite you to gather
as a family unit or gather with three or four around you
and just let's stand up and move together,
and we're going to pray for each other.
So let's do that. Now we'll transition
to praying for the church.
The apostle Paul gives us a great example
in Philippians chapter one,
it says To all the saints in Christ Jesus
who are at Philippi with overseers and deacons, grace to you
and peace from our God, our Father
and the Lord Jesus Christ.
I thank my God in all my remembrance of you,
always in every prayer of mine for you all making my prayer
with joy because of your partnership in the gospel
from the first day until now, as we pray for our church,
pray for your leadership, the staff, the elders,
your deacons list.
Lift us all up as a church that we might glorify God
and that we would be most diligent in spreading his gospel.
Let's pray for that right now.
That's always one of the favorite things
that we do as a church.
Uh, we've done that a number of times the last few years.
But to watch the body be the body in action in
that time is really sweet to me.
Uh, so thank you for engaging in that.
Maybe that was a stretch for you. That's okay.
Um, this should be a safe place for us to be able
to share a need we have.
But we know ultimately that those people in
that circle though they care for you, love you
in the end, cannot do anything to change
what you've asked for prayer for, right?
I mean, that's just the reality of our limited humanness.
But that's why we pray
because we are taking it to the one
who can do something about it.
So all over scripture, you see these times of invitation.
You see Jesus in Matthew 11 say, come
to me all who are weary and burdened.
I will give you rest.
He was echoing what God said in Isaiah 55,
come all who are thirsty.
Revelation, you hear over
and over come those who are thirsty.
And, and it's all in the context of coming to the, the,
the fountain of living water that there is no end to.
And so we are going to, as the needy ones,
create space for us to come to the one
who can meet our needs.
Hopefully, we've been doing that all morning, of course,
and you're doing that all day every day.
But but a, a purposed moment for that to happen.
So we know that in the ancient days, they would come
to the temple to bring their needs to God in a sense.
But we approach God now as the temple in prayer,
still with the holiness and reverence.
That is his holiness demands of us.
But we come because as we've said,
Christ is our intercessor.
He is the one Hebrews seven says, able
to save completely those who come to God through him,
because he always lives to intercede for them.
That's how we can come to the throne of God
above with our needs.
And so I want to invite you to come to the Lord
through Christ today.
Maybe that's the first time.
Maybe you're seeing this,
this one in your place for the first time.
Praise God for that.
But all of us come to God through Christ today.
We humbly needy, come to him.
And there's, there's something about movement
that creates a memory.
And I know throughout history, this has been debated back
and forth about coming forward in a church service.
And we, we have differing opinions in this room on that
and how it all works and all.
We're not trying to be manipulative in any way in this.
But there's something about it that when you take a step,
it creates a marker in your heart.
You don't have to come to any forward altar type thing
'cause you're the altar now to come
to Jesus that's in here.
But there might be a measure of faith
that you can step forward into today.
Plus you might need somebody to pray
with you about whatever you're feeling and facing right now.
And so in this time, whatever you're feeling facing,
there'll be a few people down here at the front,
some elders, some of our prayer team if you need to,
to talk to someone, pray with someone.
Or maybe you just need to, again symbolically,
there's nothing super spiritual about it,
but just to come kneel up here where, where you're showing
yourself not anybody else, you're not performing yourself
where your heart is A step of faith to say
to the Lord God, I need you again.
You can do that right where you sit.
You can kneel right where you are.
You can stand, you can sit, you can do whatever.
It's a posture of your heart. That's the point.
But this is the time as we sing this song, Lord, I need you
to let this be our cry.
Every one of us needs him.
And so let this be our cry as we
invite one another to come to Jesus.